bonjour claude bonjour ravi de vous
retrouver dans la matinale verte et
france un commentaire tout d'abord sur
la déclaration de jean yves le drian
hier soir à l'onu qui a comparé
finalement de jéhovah ivan à donald
trump
la manière est différente parce que en
effet joe biden et la diplomatie
américaine met les formes utilisent les
voir conventionnel monsieur blinken est
un francophone absolue mais sur le fond
en effet les positions sont très
semblables c'est à dire l'amérique
d'abord les intérêts américains d'abord
et le reste suivra alors les états unis
qui disent aussi vouloir continuer à
travailler avec la france dans la zone
indo pacifique est ce que cette crise
elle va avoir des conséquences justement
dans cette zone oui certainement d'abord
les états unis pour suivre un triple
objectif en faisant ce qu'ils ont fait
la semaine dernière le premier set
compléter leur dispositif militaire en
asie ils ont déjà un dispositif
militaire assez important puisqu'il ya
une alliance avec le japon avec 50000
kayak à l'appui une alliance avec la
corée du sud 30 mille j'y aille à
l'appui sur place et puis la fameuse
base de guan au milieu du pacifique qui
est à mi distance précisément entre
l'australie et la chine où il y à 150
mille militaires américains et puis il
ya en a pas beaucoup parlé ces jours ci
au nord de l'australie une petite base
américaine à darwin où il y a environ
deux mille soldats américains depuis
déjà quelques années à la demande
d'ailleurs de l'australie peut-être ceci
aurait pu nous mettre la puce à
l'oreille
alors elle est effectivement là c'est le
premier intérêt le deuxième intérêt que
trouvent les états unis c'est de lever
le voile sur le concept de dinde au
pacifique puisque tout le monde y met un
petit peu ce qu'il veut y mettre c'est
un concept valises et dont la diplomatie
japonaise avait avait lancé cette idée
dans le fond pour injure et ses routes
d'approvisionnement
pour assurer la liberté de circulation
dans le détroit de malacca dans les
différentes zones maritimes qui
permettent au japon de faire ses
échanges avec l'extérieur et puis là on
en vient à quelque chose de complètement
différent une alliance militaire une
alliance militaire ouvertement dirigées
contre la chine et dont le noyau serait
les états unis la grande bretagne et
l'australie le troisième avantage qu'ils
trouvent les américains c'est que à
l'appui de cette alliance militaire il
ya évidemment l'exclusivité de
fourniture des armements et qu' il est
bien entendu que si on est à beaune
allié des états unis on doit acheter
américain
et qu'elle pourrait être selon vous
claude les réactions de la france et de
l'europe un on a vu hier qu'ils avaient
fait bloc derrière paris du moins dans
leurs déclarations
quelle pourrait être la suite selon vous
en effet nos partenaires font preuve de
compassion mais le problème n'est pas la
compassion n'est pas pas les sentiments
le problème c'est me semble-t-il de
redéfinir une conception française
d'abord européenne ensuite de du concept
indo pacifique est en effet ce concept
indo pacifique doit probablement et plus
fondée sur des accords de coopération
stratégique mais avec des contenus tout
à fait différents avec chacun des pays
de la zone est pas une approche
militaire d'alliance multilatérales
comme les etats unis la grande bretagne
et l'australie sont en train de le faire
c'est complètement différent c'est un
peu la proche qui a proposé et madame
van der leyen elle a pas eu de chance
c'était le jour où monsieur joe biden
parlaient d'eux
delà de la nouvelle alliance avec
l'australie avec la grande bretagne et
par conséquent ce qu'a dit l'union
européenne a été parfaitement inaudible
cela sera repris probablement dans des
sommets la grande différence entre nos
partenaires et nous c'est que la france
a des intérêts directs dans le pacifique
sud des territoires également dans
l'océan indien alors que ce n'est pas le
cas de nos partenaires que la france par
conséquent à des navires qui
patrouillent régulièrement bien sûr
beaucoup moins que les états unis il ya
aussi la 7ème flotte qui est dans la
zone indo pacifique mais il y a
cependant entre la polynésie française
la nouvelle calédonie mayotte et le
territoire français des mouvements
constants de navires et que par
conséquent la france est en permanence
constante elle a aussi à surveiller avec
ses moyens à limiter en effet le
deuxième domaine maritime mondial en
termes de zone économique exclusive au
sens du traité sur le droit de la mer
ceux qui viennent dire espace des
responsabilités considérables et en
effet sur ce sujet comme sur la liberté
de circulation en chine en mer de chine
du sud ou dans les détroits malacca et
autres il faut que l'europe s'impliquent
est-ce que vous qui êtes un fin
connaisseur de l'inde vous allez publier
un livre à ce sujet bientôt est ce que
la france a intérêt à renforcer ses
liens avec l'inde justement dans ce
contexte ça devrait être la réponse
évidente ça dépend naturellement les
indiens les indiens comme d'autres dans
la zone eux réfléchissent qu'ils
réfléchissaient déjà avant l'événement
de la semaine dernière mais tous les
pays
avia tic se disent mais dans le fond
pourquoi est-ce que l'australie pourrait
avoir accès à la technologie des sous
marins à propulsion nucléaire et pas
nous
les japonais qui sont les alliés des
américains les corée du sud qui sont les
alliés les américains
les indiens qui cherche à maintenir une
relative équidistance mais qui ont
besoin aussi de se renforcer et auquel
en effet un certain nombre de pays vende
des armements d'ailleurs la russie est
un fournisseur traditionnel d'armement à
l'inde et à louer c'est une formule
originale un sous marin nucléaire
d'attaqué à propulsion nucléaire il ya
quelques années donc on constate que en
réalité en faisant ce qu'ils ont fait
les américains ont transgressé à
l'interdît qui était que tous les pays à
capacité nucléaire militaire
s'interdisait de transférer la
technologie des propulsions maritime
sous marine ou de surfaces à des pays
qui n'avaient pas à la technologie
nucléaire les américains l'ont fait la
semaine dernière sera probalement
beaucoup de conséquences dans les mois
et dans les années qui viennent un effet
de prolifération sans doute est en effet
les pays vont avoir à choisir entre
la russie les états unis la france la
grande bretagne les pays qui ont cette
technologie nucléaire l'australie ne l'a
pas du tout ce qui veut dire que pour
construire plus ensuite pour entretenir
ces sous-marins à propulsion nucléaire
il faudra assurément des techniciens
américains mais il faudra aussi des
officiers américains et il est probable
qu'il y aura à partir du moment où cette
flotte sera opérationnel et bien un
amiral américain dans l'état major de la
marine australienne s'est pas tout à
fait notre conception de l'indépendance
merci beaucoup que de blanchemaison
peut-être avant de nous quitter une
réaction parce que dans ce contexte les
etats-unis ont annoncé hier la reprise
des vols en provenance des pays
européens le retour des vols
internationaux attendus pour le 1er
novembre mais uniquement pour les
voyageurs vaccinés depuis mars 2020 les
états unis mettent en place de fortes
restrictions pour les voyageurs
étrangers où aller les détails de la
porte parole de la maison blanche
début novembre où nous mettrons en place
des protocoles stricts pour empêcher la
propagation du coït 19 par les passagers
des vols internationaux vers les états
unis en exigeant que les adultes
étrangères voyageant aux états unis soit
entièrement vacciner
claire est ce que pour vous c'est un
geste diplomatique ou est-ce que ça n'a
rien à voir avec la crise actuelle je
pense que d'avoir une bonne nouvelle sur
le plan économique et sur le plan humain
parce que il n'y avait plus de touristes
américains en france et c'est l'époque
où il y en a habituellement beaucoup il
ya actuellement deux grandes expositions
à voir à paris effectivement ça veut
dire le retour des touristes américains
c'est donc une bonne nouvelle également
sur le plan des affaires et il faut que
dans les deux sens les les gens puissent
circuler et avait une forte demande une
forte pression donc maintenant se pose
pas de la réciproque est bien qui sera
décidé en concertation à bruxelles il
est probable que la commission et la
plupart de nos partenaires
prôneront la réciprocité et que la
france sera très attentive à ce que les
conditions sanitaires permettent de
donner cette réciprocité merci à vous
que l'aude on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine mardi dans la matinale vers
séquence merci claude